hey YouTube a verse coming right up a
cosmic queries edition of Startalk
bioethics welcome to Startalk host Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist we've got a cosmic
queries edition of Startalk the subject
bioethics my co-host Paul Mercurio Paul
nice to see you back dude yeah thanks
for having me thanks for making some
time for us before warming up Stephen
Colbert's audience so you're right down
the street yeah yeah we're just up the
street from you here yeah provide a limo
which is nice
did we know okay yeah now you're not a
bioethicist no they're mine no we might
have thoughts on the matter yes right
right every day we went back into our
rolodex and re-invited
professor Matthew Liao Matthew welcome
back to Startalk thank you so we last
had you on stage live in front of an
audience at New York Comic Con and we
had Adam Savage with us as well we would
talk about human augmentation and
whether that would be bioethical mm-hmm
and and you said off camera you remember
that that was my birthday I we we sung
right
oh he's written on the program that that
was required so welcome back
yeah good to have you you are director
of the bioethics program the Center
footbath NYU at NYU Center for Bioethics
and New York University right here in
town it so easy date for you so we'll be
calling more on you I need to think of
these issues so we've got questions Paul
yes I haven't seen them I don't know if
if math you see now he is not and we'll
just sort of jump right in well let me
just find out what is bioethics what's
an example so on the same page yeah it's
the study of biomedical out of
biomedical mostly medical now yeah
mostly medical
it could also involve things like
artificial intelligence and sort of its
connection to healthcare yeah but AI is
not bio purpose right so right right but
it could be so what you want is silicon
ethics that's silicon that that's right
right well a lot of people are now
thinking about putting in things like
brain computer interfaces into their you
know into their brains and things like
that so the silicon and the organic
matter they're kind of merging oh so
this this complicates your job that's
right what makes it more interesting
both yes yeah what's the fastest-moving
areas AI is it is it genetic
manipulation like what's yeah I think
both of them are occurring concurrently
so there's the CRISPR technology gene
editing technology that's sort of really
advancing I like that because if you can
mutate my genes so I don't have to go to
the gym and then there's the artificial
intelligence people are using that for
things like cancers you know they're a
pathologists are looking at sort of
these images the AI is getting really
good at pattern recognition and image
recognition they can spot sort of cancer
cells almost as good as pathologists now
okay so so but that wouldn't be an
ethical thing that's just the Machine
can do it better so let the machine do
it right right so ethics would be now
the Machine knows your condition and
it's connected to the Internet
yeah and so a hacker might have access
yeah or say that you know the insurance
company owned you you know knows the
algorithms and tries to hack it and sort
of make it look like it's not cancer
when it is or something like that or
sort of issues to do with privacy well
he's right to think about it you have a
very diabolical which would you like to
have dessert you like what do you mean
by that
are you fond around people I mean I mean
you're from but like to you like if they
want to do something a little like
inappropriate like the little extra gas
in when nobody notices you go like no
there's an ethical issue there
are you is there well they're they're
surveys that say that ethicists are
necessarily necessarily more ethical
really so they you know apparently they
steal they steal sort of books from
libraries only don't call their mothers
you know on Mother's Day things like
that so yeah I call my I call my mom
okay so it's not they saying do as you
say not as you do that's right yeah
that's right that's right so what
questions you Paul
we're gonna start with the patreon
question yes his Allah's on to the
patreon yeah absolutely we love them
this is Oliver gigas I'm sorry if I'm
mispronouncing that personally I feel
that we the general public aren't
talking enough about subjects like
bioethics and AI even though they are
clearly going to be a huge part of the
future do either of you feel the same
way and if so how can we better educate
ourselves on these subjects I completely
agree and so one of the things I tried
to do is to talk to the public about
some of these issues and and you know
work in this area things like sort of
gene editing and artificial intelligence
so how much of it is just a fear mm-hmm
that people don't understand the
technology and so we fear everything we
don't understand I think that it doesn't
come down to that at some level yeah I
think a lot of it is that just people
are scared of new technologies they
they're very cautious and there's
science fiction writers that take it to
the worst topic right future right
that's right there you know the robots
are after us you're gonna kill it
oh yeah super intelligence is coming and
so people get really scared and they
think oh we should not do any of this
stuff and that's also bad for science
it's bad for progress yeah but I just
bought a car where I don't have a
dipstick anymore and I just hit a button
and it tells me the oil the oil always
yeah and I'm a little weirded out by
that like I want the physical thing get
off my lawn what if the oil companies
have adjusted the minute the program of
that so that it's falsely telling me I
need oil to make extra money yeah
we should hang out you see what I'm
saying yeah so you sound like about this
already
okay just not to not to hang you out to
dry
yeah when the dashboard became all
screen without a mechanical speedometer
right we're just it turns on yeah and in
what turns on it has your mileage and
I'm thinking this is a screen come on
now okay there's no mechanical mile but
how does it whoo I got all old man on it
I unplugged my toaster every night
because I think it's gonna catch fire I
don't know the whole thing is sort of
overwhelming for people on some level
yeah so I think you're you hit on
exactly the right issue and the issue
here is trust like trusting technology's
trucks trust in algorithms trusts in
like how do we make sure that when we
were all these technologies there's
trust and and that's the job of the
scientists but also the Ephesus and
having the educator yeah and the
educator yeah to make sure that we can
actually trust these things I got a
question that I remembered getting asked
of the public mm-hmm and I remembered at
the time what my answer was then and it
still is today but the public in the day
answered differently here's the question
if the something happens you're on an
airplane and there's something goes
wrong with the airplane mm-hmm okay and
what would you trust a button that says
auto fly this thing home or a trained
Navy pilot who decorated trained Navy
pilot to bring it home it was a to pilot
of course and I'm thinking no just a
fight with his wife and just down the
bottle of scotch in the airport the
button didn't have a bottle so and today
I mean what my my thinking has borne out
because planes are designed that they
cannot actually be flown by a human
being there's too many surfaces that are
under control
right of the computer that's why flying
is so stable ya know so that's it's do
you trust the technology or not that's
right yeah and so in order to trust the
technology you have to make sure that
it's safe it's tested it's reliable it
can be sort of a Vasseur adversarially
attacked and that's why sort of ephesus
like myself we ask these you know
questions like things like well what
happens you know we imagine these
hypothetical examples like what happens
if the insurance company is trying to
cheat you and do certain things or you
know if the hackers trying to hack into
the algorithm or the imaging thing you
know like there ways of that there's
plenty of evidence that some of these
imaging machine learning technologies
can be hacked I think that's amazing to
me is like science and especially what
you do is so sort of on track with
ethics it's a microcosm because in a
society in general ethics seems to be
the last thing it's like worrying about
table manners at a game of Thrones red
wedding right like you just sort of you
guys have this ability to really think
about these things like there's some
conversation about like well eh I could
like destroy the planet well humans are
already kind of doing that yeah I can do
it better
what's complaining yeah well that's you
know so some people think that you know
the super intelligence you know if there
were to be created they're gonna decide
that hey we're destroying the you know
we're destroying the planet and one way
to stop to help the plan is by like
killing all of us you know because we're
vipers because we're viruses my wife
uses for me from the matrix yes yeah
Hydra Paul yes you got more questions I
do Raymond Oh young start talk radio net
no question about morals and science are
there any circumstances in science where
it would be acceptable to bypass ethics
in human experimentation if the findings
hmm would lead to greater good oh that's
it was that the entire Nazi medical yeah
enterprise yeah and they and the in the
Tuskegee study that's the Tuskegee study
yes yeah just tell us about one or both
of those and then yeah tell us what
that's a great question here yeah so the
Nazis were sort of experimenting they
human sort of on humans they're sort of
for example they're taking them up into
the airplanes to see how much pressure a
human being can withstand and these are
mostly Jews and other undesirables
that's you know in the in the Germanic
model that's right if you right yeah and
and they you know apparently some people
say that they were able to find out you
know things that we wouldn't have
otherwise you know found but still I
think that it's very clear now that you
know we need to sort of buy by these
ethical norms and we should you know we
should we need to stick to research
ethics and they're sort of since the
there's something called the Belmont
report that came out as a result of the
Tuskegee experiments and to describe the
ski game yeah briefly it's it's where
it's the experiment where there are
these subjects and they were given
syphilis and they were they weren't told
that Authority had city already has said
but they were totally were being treated
but in fact they were in that's right
and then the observation was to see the
progress of syphilis in the human body
that that and and all the subjects were
black men that's right right that's
right after that when when it was
discovered basically that was the birth
of bioethics as a field you know you
know base people decided that we
shouldn't be doing this
there should be you know we didn't look
at there are sort of different
principles that were being proposed
things like do no harm you need to make
sure that the research benefits the
subjects and then you need to make sure
that there's autonomy there's informed
consents so a lot of the ballot they
call principles came out as you know
interesting yeah okay do no harm that's
in there that's pretty Hippocratic oath
yeah yeah yeah but talk to Mickey Rourke
surgeons I mean they're not violated
that thing a waste of Sunday right I
mean isn't that sort of part of like the
medical field Smee seems like that is it
almost was it fair to say the first sort
of a area where bioethics and was sort
of really founded in some way yeah and
yet it seems like that profession
they're all over the place I mean this
pimple popper shows and I think they're
attentive so not to harm even if they
end up doing harm right yeah right
yeah and go wrong you know wasn't their
intent yeah right it's like me with a
bad joke yeah yeah and I can't bring it
back okay so what you're saying is this
is an interesting enlightened posture
which is no matter what is going on I
will do no harm to you even if having
done harm to you saves the lives of a
hundred other people mm-hmm because the
individual is has the priority in this
exchange and its relationship that's
right so that's that's enlightened
mm-hmm and and even profound I think is
the converse of this that with Neil just
mention this whole issue with measles
now and how is I'm really fascinated by
that so someone it's it morally against
a vaccination because they think it
causes autism and yet they're putting
entire communities at risk right right
where what is the conversation in your
field now about that yeah I mean it's
and what do you serve at a musil's party
salmonella cake I'm just curious like
what do you think that team seems to me
yeah yeah so my own view about
vaccination is that we have a public
duty to you know be vaccinated right and
so that comes from sort of not harming
other people so we have an obligation
not to harm other people and so and the
complicating the the issue with
vaccination is that you know it it's the
bodily integrity we also have a right to
bodily integrity so some people think
that we shouldn't be forced to be
vaccinated if we don't want to and I
think that's right but I also think that
that doesn't mean that we ourselves
don't have a duty to be vaccinated so we
should do it voluntarily so so there's a
greater good that's right that a greater
good argument that overrides the
personal integrity well you can personal
integrity is something that you can
waive it's your right but you can waive
it right in these cases and so in this
case I think that we have a duty to
serve the public by getting vaccinated
you kind of straddle the fence there
yeah I want to create a law you should
resident you know that was an unethical
answer
no no that it's interesting it's really
complicated yeah and they actually dealt
with a little bit of this in Planet of
the Apes because you have the
intelligent chimps and they're doing
medical experiments on the humans that
you can captured mm-hm and we think
that's a bomb an abomination because
we're human do that on lab animals all
the time right so who we just say that
they can't do that and yet the quality
of our life is much better because we do
it so it's sort of this whole yeah
balancing act yeah that's where we have
you yeah yeah okay experiments on you
that's next week you come back and I Jun
Jin and we take just let me just I can't
let this go is there so there's not even
some numerical threshold where you would
say harm to one person if it saves a
hundred mm-hmm or thousand or a million
yeah or billion yes so there so there's
this view it's called threshold
deontology and it's a threshold
deontology deontology that's right and
it's the view that there's a threshold
and when you cross that threshold and it
might be okay to harm somebody in order
but isn't it arbitrary and who decides
what the threshold is yes that's why we
have him as a team yeah yes so you're
you you're absolutely right so where's
the threshold it's not okay to say kill
one to save five people my that okay to
kill one to save a million right or what
if they are young people what's the
threshold of I've is okay no it's not
okay yeah okay but way okay so but then
you're saying is let's say no joke here
Neil is one of the five then there's a
million and you're saying it's okay it's
it's okay you've devalued his life based
on the number of people that yeah that
doesn't seem to be any logic to that
yeah so some people say that well if we
were to think that it's okay to kill
Neil in order to save a billion people
well you're just you're very smart
extremely intelligent so you're worth a
billion before like a dog then all this
is like it this is the rowboats right
throw out a weekend yeah you keep the
criminal that's my wedding by the way
how would we kill Neal just out of could
it be a slow death so so tell me that
it's called the the threshold deontology
threshold deontology yeah and so that's
you know the view that there's a
threshold beyond which it's okay to harm
somebody in order to save the greater
number so at the towards the end of the
movie the secret of Santa vitória this
is I don't know if it's fiction or if
it's based on a real story there's a
town in Italy that had this or there
might have been France this amazing wine
producing for their fame of world famous
for their wine the Nazis were coming to
and they don't want the Nazis to get it
so they hid the wine in a cave and
bricked it over and then put moss on it
and league made it look aged and then
the Nazis came in looking for the wine
and they couldn't find it and they
scoured the countryside and they decided
that whoever's the next person that
comes out in the street they're gonna
torture them and find out where the wine
is hid it so the townspeople agreed to
let the prisoner out of the is that
you're free to go and the principle is
Brigid didn't know any of this it was
just a thing the prisoner comes out in
the notches torture Wow and they
couldn't figure out where it was and
then Nazis leave Jesus would have been
hilarious if the guy they torture was a
Sami heir and they just we gotta take a
quick break and when we come back more
on bioethics really cool when star talk
continues
back on Startalk we're talking about
bioethics my co-host my guest co-host
this episode Paul Mercurio Moll hey you
tweet home mm-hmm what give me your
Twitter handle at Paul Mercurio at okay
very creative I had my people we
gathered around all wrong
by the way it's Emmy see you are i/o and
I only say that because there's an
Australian actor Paul Mercurio NERC URI
Oh work URI which is actually how I
spell my name but he got in the actors
Union before I did he was in Strictly
Ballroom and exit to Eden whoa I did my
first guest appearance on a sitcom also
you have to change your name I'm like
why did I bust the law something like
know this guy so it's M ECU ra oh and in
retrospect I should have just changed it
to like Smith school yeah might be the
planet Mercury oh yeah yeah and we have
professor Matthew Liao welcome and
you're head of the a bioethics Center at
New York University and we're reading
question we've got questions we have our
fan base you have another question for
Maddie you're Maddie the rest of this is
hey Haider from Instagram do you think
crispers technology will allow us to
take the DNA of an athlete or maybe a
bounty hunter tweak it to be even better
and stronger than the original and then
take the DNA and create a clone army can
we do that and if so please send the
instructions to my bunker no I just
added okay so i yes I think that's
possible I mean sort of the fact that
some people are stronger than others is
partly genetics right and so if we can
figure out that you know but don't say
that it's not Paul will say I'm not
getting muscles cuz its genetic
Twinkies have nothing to do with it I
did say partly partly yeah yeah
and so like LeBron James you know
instead of you know because of his genes
right and so if you can set of sequence
well he's big because it was James but
is he athletic because of his genes yeah
he needs to work out yes okay so there's
definitely you get your height and other
things very bluntly from your genes
that's right that's right and so we can
figure that part out
so and then you can imagine using CRISPR
technology to then put that into sort of
either gametes or embryos and then
create you know offsprings that have
those traits so this is this is in our
future I think so I think this is this
is something that can be done so well so
so we will breed into our own
civilization
yeah entire classes of people for our
own entertainment well is that anything
different from sumo wrestlers in Japan
it's called the one and done rule in
college basketball we're doing basically
like yeah tell me about sumo wrestling
no it's not a genetic thing but they
they're specially treated and especially
fed that's right to be swimmer wrestlers
that's right yeah and that's a cultural
thing they don't live long and everybody
knows this I don't think they've reached
40 age 40 yeah so so is that really any
different from doing that genetically so
that's what you know so people talk
about designer babies and the ethics of
designer babies like so there's the
question of whether we can do it but
then there's also whether we should be
doing this and I think it's very dress
you know ask they're really good you
haven't even wear right which is that
we're already doing a lot of this you
know this hyper parenting yeah look it's
like Serena Williams and you know Venus
but that's different than manipulating
through CRISPR manipulating what the
result is the same
yeah not different yes so the question
is what's the difference yeah what's the
difference one psychological and the
other is through genetic yes so the
means are different that's definitely
right but why does that make a normative
difference right why is it sort of
ethically different when we do it at the
genetic level as opposed to after the
you know sort of like after the child is
so maybe it's it's because uh maybe I
can you might genetically bred me this
way but I can choose to not do this
right but can you have you have bred him
in a way not to fight who he is and what
he is yeah yeah but maybe I'll say I'd
rather just be a poet and then you can't
stop me
whereas otherwise if you're raising me
this other way then there's all this
conflict yeah you know go ahead
each of these squares whatever we're at
stay at the piano and write it's
conflict at home whereas you can be
genetic you have a genetic propensity
but then just decline yeah
the option yeah boring house that I'd
rather be like I don't have a mom and
then you know yeah well the problem is
what if you also genetically modified
the motive motivations so that the child
wants to be a super athlete or super
pianist could you make me want to be
Neil deGrasse maybe you know I just want
to be able to talk like this yes it's
possible and it could happen yeah we
need more of you the ethicist around at
that time yeah try they say no where yes
to it right good okay launchpad cat
Instagram is there any such committees
that regulates new technologies such as
genetic tech or AI and puts regulators
in place preemptively to prevent it from
being used for amoral things like
eugenics or something of that sort
so the US has a sort of these are my
people eugenics is right Genesis ya know
to remind people what eugenics autogenic
society it means well born and so it
basically you know the Nazis who are
trying to breed these people to sort of
you know like a certain race or certain
class of people thinking that some genes
are better than others and there's even
at a time when the concept of gene was
not really they just knew that if you
breed to people who are desirable yeah
presumably you'll get a desirable person
and then you prevent others who are
undesirable from breeding and then you
can systematically shift the balance in
the population and to be able to be a
demographic who you want and care about
so the Aryan ideal it was then what was
sought that is not happening in a way
with breeding dogs and breeding hybrids
and sort of breeding implants and so
like Irish Setters are out of their
minds because they've been bred so much
we have a dog that we adopted it's like
a mutt and she's totally killed yeah but
breed breeding breeding doing it
with plants and animals that's right
other animals that's right but it's
really gonna be a board that's gonna
oversee this preemptively I mean I said
this before but like look at the medical
profession there are a lot of
questionable things that are going on a
medical profession yeah and there's a
board that oversees that yeah
preemptively the board to have emphasis
on it that's right that's right there's
there's sort of different research
committees they have oversight sort of
IRB so there is you know research boards
and institutional research brewery yeah
yeah and then they have ephesus on on
those boards to look over research look
over the experiments to make sure that
they're ethical the problem is that with
these IRB ease it's said all right if
there's something like that yeah
we're not allowed to we the scientific
community yeah their rules about what
animals you can do laboratory tests on
really right like chimpanzees there are
certain things you can't do that's and
that you can and depending on whatever
someone's judgment and some panels
judgment yeah as to the value of that
animal to the echos sphere or do
whatever yeah and other than PETA if
you're doing it to a rat I don't think
anyone can I was there saying the rat
poor things get slammed every time yeah
so do you think it can be effective
going forward
yeah so the I mean it's only effective
if the researchers are responsible
that's right okay that's right yeah and
also the value of the research has to
justify whatever research that you're
doing so you can't just sort of you know
torture these rats for fun you can't you
cannot right so that's very unethical
right and so told me that you know so in
order to do research even on animals
you've been on rats and mice you have to
be able to justify it to an
institutional research board you have to
sort of say why is this necessary and
there's no other way you have to show
that there's no other way oh yes just of
less harmful way of doing it the least
harmful way of doing there's not the
rats fault that doesn't have hair on its
tail this world does it's really pointy
nose it's fall
its fault it eats your garbage well now
it's my I'm sorry I put my garbage nut
and rat eats your garbage you don't like
dead pigeon right rats with wings hmm
we should Scotia show friend on
Instagram if in the future our noble
intentions lead to the practice of
genetically editing fetuses for
preventing birth defects and future
diseases how do we avoid the pitfall of
creating designer babies and the
possible repercussions of genetic
inequality caste systems etc and would
it uh would it even be a pitfall at all
yes so that's right like would it even
be a pitfall at all maybe this is
something we should think about doing
maybe they're good reasons to do it for
example to do what to genetically have
designed our babies to engage in genetic
editing so this is where we were talking
about earlier that people as soon as you
know when they think about new
technologies they get very scared but
maybe they're good uses of these
technologies so just for for for example
if we want to sort of go engage in if we
want to go to the moon or go to space we
want to make sure that we're more
radiation radiation resistant mmhmm
right and so there's maybe there's some
sort of genetic thing basis where we can
sort of be more radiation resistant and
so that's something that we should look
into if you want us or them so did you
breed these people for certain jobs yeah
yeah but this idea of like creating the
perfect human like I mean I don't I
don't even know anybody wants that I
mean everybody hates Tom Brady and I'm a
Patriots fan saying that here's where I
would take that I would say isn't so
much of what we are what we've been
through to overcome what we're not mmm
so that if you come out perfect then
where does your character get developed
mmm where's your sense you're
interacting in an imperfect world right
so your perfection
is always challenged well I'm just
saying who you are is almost always what
you have overcome in life absolutely if
you're perfect you there's nothing for
you to overcome what do you got to show
for anything are you saying it's
unachievable to create a perfect person
no you can paper a person but they will
achieve nothing stuff happen to them hey
Doc I was supposed to be perfect and I'm
not what's going on here look at the
real achievers in life they've overcome
something yes
a broken family there's a thing they
have a list but they've got it they have
a limp
that's like Everest gave me a list of
people that things that people with who
were rejected you know that it was like
Edison
yes the Bell no one no one's gonna want
to talk to each other far apart through
a box and they were rejected and
rejected and overcame yeah right that's
I'm saying so if you're perfect you
might be of no use to anyone right yes
so I think there there are two things to
say there so one is that you know human
goals will change like the better you
get so you know like my kids when
they're five years old they like to play
go fish right but now they're 10 years
old they don't play go fish anymore it's
too boring
right because you've kind of outgrown
that right and so you can imagine that
when we get smarter there are other
things there are other challenges you
know that we don't even know we don't
even know if right now right and then
the that the flip side of that is you
know if you really think that there's
really value to being imperfect then
that can be you know there's a challenge
[Laughter]
real quick real quick
another question okay here we go Patrick
Lynn Facebook are there any red lines
that we should not cross or maybe never
cross in science and then ethics and a
related question are there any ethical
red lines today that you think should be
rolled back oh good one
and we don't have time to answer that
you have to take a break when we come
back
the red line should you cross it or not
on Startalk
back on Startalk bioethics is the
subject of this edition cosmic queries
Matthew meow your RF assist you you're
head of a whole Center for Bioethics
that everybody comes to you with their
problems how that works and always good
to have you Paul so when we when we left
off there was a question about crossing
red lines yeah this is Patrick Lynn
Facebook are there any red lines that we
should not cross and related question is
have there been any red lines that you
feel we've crossed that should be rolled
back yeah yeah well I think there are
many red lines that we shouldn't cross
so some people are I mean just you know
creating humans that'll be like slave
humans for example I mean that's that's
an obvious one doesn't that happen
anyway if you create humans who are
perfect then the humans who are not
created perfect or left as slave to the
perfect well you really hate perfection
then you're making a slave class without
purposely making a slave class yeah so
there's this view that I mean even in
our society now sort of people have
differential abilities right but we
think that everybody has equal like
they're all they all have the same moral
status yes yeah and so we could stay
under the eyes of the law that's right
that's right and so we could still have
that even if you have like some people
who were perfect and other people not as
perfect we would be enslaved by yeah and
how about red lines that we have crossed
that you would roll back today I got one
yeah I'm old enough I'm old annoying to
remember the announcement of the first
test-tube baby that was born that was
banner headlines test-tube baby yeah and
today that's not even an interesting
point to raise on a first date whether
you were in vitro or in utero that
conceived what are you like dating no
but there was a day that might have been
a thing yeah I'm a test-tube baby yeah
there's like wow
tell me about it it's a really good
point right right and so and back then
people say are we playing God by
fertilizing eggs in a test-tube and now
it's like of course you're doing it this
is this is the fertility aid that goes
on every day for so many couples
oh I bet that that would be a line that
existed back then that we cross and now
you'd roll it back because we're all
just accustomed to it why did you agree
actually we just ran a conference on the
ethics of donor conception two weeks ago
NYU and there were all these donor
conceived individuals and they were
saying that they shouldn't have been
born should not have should not have
been born why yeah they were because
they feel that like they don't know who
their genetic parents are they feel very
isolated from yeah you know there's just
a lot of psychological this idea of God
I mean if you're an atheist right like
so this serious about this thing where
does religion creep into this right good
point so like people start to go well
panels typically have a pastor or
somebody yeah that brings a religious
philosophy to the argument I don't
religion is not a part of my life on any
level why am i leaving to some ephemera
that explains everything about you
[Laughter]
that's my tour the soul with stand-up
comedy you're going to hell religion
decides it so how does religion fold
into this and so religious ethics I
guess yeah religion so some people look
at X from a religious standpoint so
there's like divine command Theory well
with God - or with God command in
certain situations so so they would look
at these issues from that I'm speaking
for God on the assumption that they
understand the mind of God for having
read books that they presume God wrote
[Laughter]
well there's a view there's the natural
law of view that what God would want is
what our best reasoning you know
whatever we come up with our best
reasoning that's a time yeah at the time
yeah and so that's sort of a natural law
and you alluded to this bringing a
perfect person into the world right this
I do bioethics and whatever and it's
like but then you look at the world we
live in right we're obsessed okay we're
gonna make Janet genetically-enhanced
corn so we have better nutrition so that
we're in better shape to kill each other
right yeah it's sort of like I just feel
like do we do we need a gene for
rational thought
get your people to yeah well they're
like a lot of people talking about moral
enhancement like you know can we enhance
ourselves morally so that were less
aggressive and more sympathetic and
empathetic to the plights of I say screw
other people oh yeah yeah go for it
we are gonna go to dickson clinton
instagram combining crisper and ever
advancing AI will be the downfall of
humankind right how many years do I have
before I'm being murdered by cyborg
overlords why are you gonna stop going
to the movies yeah so when do we all die
yeah oh we're all gonna die so you know
some people like Ray Kurzweil thinks
that you know by 2050 we'll have super
intelligence other Sciences AI
scientists right Chris well I think we
have interviewed him on Startalk in a
live taping yeah yeah and so and other
people say it's not so you know like
they're less optimistic but they think
that maybe by 2100 we'll have super
intelligence and so and so there's a
real-life issue what happens when you
have these really smart AI that are you
know that are smarter than us we become
their slaves we become their slaves oh
if we're monkey mm-hmm maybe maybe we'll
just become their pets yeah or maybe I
went too far they are all right this is
Chris Cherry Instagram hi Chris from the
Sunshine Coast Australia not Austria
Australia should we fear DNA samples
being required by health insurance
companies and employers potentially you
could be discriminated against because
of something you have no control over
yeah
Chris it's called race and ethnicity
absolute you alluded to this but yeah no
absolutely I think that's a real worry
that as you know more and more of our
information are available you know
through genetic testing etcetera
etcetera
um you know companies might use that in
sort of inappropriate ways or unethical
ways so an ethics board would say no
insurance companies will not have access
to your DNA that's right or maybe a
society that maybe that's something
that's beyond like ethics board
something so don't leave a coffee cup
that you sip from in the in the
insurance office yeah they might take
place wah wah we got a lightning round
okay ready yeah so you're gonna ask you
a question and I and Matthew you have to
enter it in a soundbite okay pretend
you're on the evening news and the only
gonna sound bite you okay go okay this
is Justin vildan from Instagram what's
your opinion on ethics of manipulation /
creation of AI in general could we
manipulate with it so far to come close
to something resembling our own
consciousness not yet when it's it's
hard to say so I don't think we have
figured out what consciousness is or you
know sort of the biological substrates
of consciousness to be able to do that
yet none of the machine learning
technologies right now can do that today
we understand consciousness how soon
after that do we program that into
computers the next day is this deja Nero
Instagram do you think AI and humans
will be integrated or DNA editing can be
used to create superhumans like we see
in x-men
I'd like that because if you can edit
the DNA what do you need the computer
for that's yeah that's a question right
so the computers might be faster right
so they have more bandwidth the brain is
sort of very slow it thinks very slowly
so you can imagine that once you can
kind of up men through some sort of
brain computer interface it gives you
vast amount of storage space capacity
upgrade and perfect memory improvement
it's not as arguing about what happened
yeah no I didn't forget the vitamin
let's go to the videotape Yeah right
that's uh this is a theme on many
episodes of black mirror by the way you
should check it out
okay now galaxy star girl Xbox Instagram
do you think whoa
I know excellent I'd love it and as an
underscore but I left that out do you
think the future of AI in society will
bring about the less need for doctors
I believe doctors will still be needed
just in fewer numbers yeah I'm not sure
about the numbers but you know we're
gonna have wearables that are going to
be able to attract our heartbeats how
to--let's are gonna be foota you know
kind of you know analyze house tool you
know and sort of tell us whether we're
healthy and not or not and then that's
gonna be sent to doctor you want your
toilet talking about but I I think it's
coming smart toilets are coming so
that's sort of the that's the next
business you know this is from Christian
Versailles Instagram I would like to
know what are the considerations to
judge something as quote good or bad in
the aspects of modifying and organizing
an organism genetically humans for
instance mmm so I have this view that
humans need some basic HIPAA capacities
things like the ability to be able to
think to have deep personal
relationships and things like that and
so I think that whatever we do with
genetic modification we shouldn't
interfere with those core human
capacities and and if saya and the flip
side of that is if an embryo like an
offspring that doesn't have those
capacities then we should try to make
sure that they have those in whatever
genetic way what about genetic way
beyond that it's just it's just luxury
items that's right off of a shopping
list like one more here we go
that'd be a good one dude wow there's a
lot of pressure here okay this is a
dagan pleek Instagram we will attempt
will we attempt to splice human DNA with
other animal DNA to make mutants of a
sort with this conflict for our ethics
and what are your thoughts on creating
new humanoid species
the scent or isn't it more Minotaur yeah
yeah that's a great question so it
relates to what I just said earlier I
think as long as we don't affect those
core fundamental capacities sometimes we
might look into these type of you know
like augmentations these you know
combining with animal would you want a
splice for the human I can show you
would you want to be up to me yes let's
say my dog so you're Mike sniffing in my
concluding remarks yes yes so we got
time for just some some reflective
thoughts so Paul won't you go first
um I I just think all of these questions
that you deal with it's endlessly
fascinating and on some level open-ended
right
you seem to have the most subjective
sort of job in a way but you like the
common person you ever met
yeah which means you're up to no good
you know something that we don't and we
didn't get much into this but this I
know you've done a lot of work with
manipulation of memory for PTSD rape
victims etc and erasing thought is that
making advanced a part of your TED talk
is that right yes yes can I have it in
September cuz I'm going to a reunion in
high school and I wanna wipe out the
memory of asking Renee Sherlock for the
prom and getting turned down twice I
want to wait very fairly far along
that's that's pretty far alone but you
got unfortunately got to take it within
12 hours of asking someone to a prom so
you know which is a short term and
that's right it stops it from
consolidating into the long-term memory
there's there's another thing something
called zip so there's this idea that I
mean anything called zip after the show
so Matthew give us some some reflective
concluding remarks here so I think these
that there are a lot of these new
technologies there on the horizon I
think they have a lot of promises
but we also should worry about their you
know we should be mindful of their
ethical implications and you know I
think they can further keeping you
employed that's right so that and I
think ultimately our aim is to sort of
create human well-being human
flourishing and so we want to make sure
that these technologies do that so here
here's what I think not that anyone
asked wait what do you think the fact
that you can crossbreed the genetics of
different species at all we do this we
do this often in the food chain is a
reminder that all life has some common
DNA so we should not be surprised that
you can take a fish DNA put in a tomato
it's just a reminder that we're all
related genetically so what I think to
myself is the human form is not some
perfect example of life I'd like the
fact that newts can regenerate their
limbs where is the gene sequence for
that let's put that in humans and give
it first to veterans who have lost their
legs or arms and we grow our limbs yeah
if a nuke can do it and we have genetic
editing why can't we do it and why
haven't we and well maybe that's to come
but I'd look at what is possible in the
experimentation of the biodiversity that
is life on Earth and say why can't we
have some of that and that is a thought
from the cosmic perspective
I want to thank Matthew Liao a second
time on Startalk we will bring you back
for sure
thank you all right and have fun down
that run but you know work hard and make
a better world for us or help us make a
better world for ourselves
keep creating issues that aren't really
issues
by the way best mind eraser better than
vodka but rights are even invented takes
out those cells right there
well always good to have you thank you
snot all right I've been and will
continue to be Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist coming to you
from my office at the Hayden Planetarium
at the American Museum of Natural
History and as always I bid you to keep
looking up
[Music]